because impress your host
Erica knows Camila real organization
[Applause]
we can do this the easy way or the hard
way
they're the newest just that we will do
stuff away
fabien animal she looks cute ready
because the new series narcos mexico has
everyone tuning in for a taste of the
criminal cartel oh man well today we're
excited to welcome the actress who plays
the character Isabella but Batista say
hello - oh my God we're so excited to
have you here today first off
congratulations on such an incredible
role it's gotta be so awesome for you
now the show is out and yeah it's out it
came out on Friday so it's been out
three four days yeah and it's been
having an incredible just to everybody
across the board and liking it breathing
about it what is the line of the best
reaction so far that you've gotten that
really has just hit hard yeah there's
just too many people don't want to marry
me
are these proposals uh there any chance
I don't know a lot of people also raving
because you're one of the few females on
set I believe the only one that's on set
of narcosis Mexico right now I mean
there there's other actresses it but
might be the only drug dealer right okay
explain to everyone who may not have
seen it yet a little bit about your
character is she based on someone real
life or no she is based on Conan real
life there was a woman who in the 80s
because we were coming in to tell the
story of a conflict that had the began
in the 80s that is the root of what
we're living right now and the the war
on drugs so there was a woman in the 80s
who there's been a lot of fictional
characters that were there were that
happened based on her and she was mainly
nicknamed the queen okay
the queen of a lot of things the Oh
Sharon cocaine the queen of so she was
the one who introduced the the character
of Felix Guyana the the character the
Diego Luna plays you go to the world of
cocaine trafficking okay they were they
were dealing with weed and and just just
marijuana and she came in and said what
about cocaine
my so how did you prepare for this role
was there any research that you got into
the character yes there's a lot there
was a lot of books and a lot of material
especially because this show is what I
like about this show is is one of the
few very responsible shows that talk up
that shed light in an issue that needs
to be talked about and remembered
because as we remember our past then we
understand our present and we can then
change our future and our conditions the
present conditions so they gave us a lot
of a lot of material and there was also
I think there's also just so much
separation because it's so recent so
there was a lot of people that that told
me about those days how they live them
and how they experience them yeah and
you talked a little bit about Diego Luna
but but Michael Pena there's so many
amazing people in the cast what was it
like working with them it seems like you
guys have gotten so close
oh yeah well actually it was really
interesting is that the producers from
narcos
they're all American but they have this
incredible I they just every time they
make a season it's like they cast it's
like they know we all we all can work
together well and most of the people in
the show I knew them from before we grew
up working together right so it was just
one big party to be together Joaquin
co-ceo they're not worth that iPhone so
those si yeah everybody is it's just
it's like family it's like being me and
him sounds like a natural yeah and I
hear there's a there's a party in the
text messages you guys have a group chat
going on yeah when the show came out
that kind of started it because you know
it was like there were some people that
were here some people that had gone back
to Mexico right after the premiere so I
was just trying to figure out who was
here and then everybody was gone it was
just testin me okay so and so we started
texting everybody like Oh have you seen
so far about this and then so it's it's
just the week we keep it together right
then you gotta shut the group chats off
because it just gets too much I know one
thing a lot of people love about this
particular series is that everything is
in Spanish pretty much and you have to
look at the captions right how is being
bilingual helped your career well just
the impact on you know on your yeah I
mean I
I'm mexican-american so people that hear
me sin and luckily because I travelled a
lot because of my parents
I speak perfect Spanish and then I speak
English too like so people don't think
that I can speak one or another so it's
always a great surprise for for people
the way you speak Spanish oh wait you
speak English I want to bring it back to
the cast really quick because I love
that you guys are just such a family
Diego Luna what was it like working with
him oh it's great everybody's just
asking about Diego Luna there's other
cast member because we have no no he is
great he I think I think Diego is one of
the actors in my country that a lot of
the the young or upcoming actors look up
to so to work with him and to also talk
to him is really great because he's such
a responsible Mexican citizen you know
he's always going against the trying to
tackle the issues that need to be
addressed and so it's I think that's
part of what he chose to work on the
show right no of course we talked a lot
about the fact that you guys know knew
each other a lot before getting on set
is there someone that's a dream guest
star or a dream cameo that you'd have in
mind for season 2 a dream cameo I I
think I I don't I don't know I think you
know the see someone there's gotcha
the Luis Guzman okay anyways because
mine is a great friend of mine so I'm
like why don't you write a scene me to
know like it's a Bella and gotcha yeah
we're like we always talked about having
a cooking show because that's all we do
were just like don'twe you guys do like
so when you're not filming and you guys
are all together what can we find you
guys doing cooking what else just hang
out yes exciting I think yeah I mean we
have because a lot of us come from we
shoot in Mexico City and some of them
live there but a lot of us are also
somewhere else and so we stay in the
same hotel and it's just like one big
salsa party after another karaoke
pretty great Louisville team thank you
so much and congratulations thank you so
much yeah
be sure to check out Tracy Ruusan
Netflix's original series narcos mexico
streaming right now and get ready to
marathon it especially this holiday
weekend yeah thanks again girl first
stopping by
[Music]
[Applause]